it's crazy I wrote this [ __ ] in 2008 14  years ago and there was a chapter called  the greatest marketing strategy ever and  it was a one word chapter it was care  I got a lot of feedback from it in the  best way through the years but  going this meeting right now  and it's just so obvious to me that this  is the [ __ ] answer  like  if you don't care about the person when  you're marketing if you just want their  [ __ ] money you want to take that  money and buy a [ __ ] yacht the [ __ ]  do you think's gonna happen that [ __ ] is  [ __ ] soulless start caring about the  people you're marketing to sell [ __ ] you  actually believe in  give an actual [ __ ]  like [ __ ]  care about being creative do good [ __ ]  no entitlement work for it all that just  [ __ ] care